but also now I'm seeing a sight gag of
this man crashing through the office
flying through the windshield into a
casket and then it closing which is
which would be that's a rim shot that's
it hey we want to give a hearty thank
you to our sponsor Factor you can cross
meal prepping off your list this holiday
season with Factor you can skip the meal
planning grocery shopping chopping
prepping and cleaning up and get factors
fresh never frozen meals delivered to
your door they're ready in Just 2
minutes so all you have to do is heat
them up and enjoy head to factor
meals.com
dp50 and use the code dp50 to get 50%
off that's code dp50 dp50 at factor
meals.com
dp50 and get
50% off hey Tes welcome to another
episode of Dum people Town population
you population marale Justin marale
welcome to the show good to be back we
love good to have you back every time we
see you at The Comedy Store I'm like
number one it makes us happy same number
one Mak you're like I will say this you
know half of going and going to clubs
and Dan you agree Danel you agree with
this too let's find out half of it is
doing your set the other half is hanging
out with your friends yes yeah it's the
best there are people who are not a good
hang in The Green Room you know this
true you know this to be true let's talk
about each one by get it let's drag them
tea no but then oh are you here to make
this horrible yeah that's what yeah oh
are you here to make this this is
horrible people
Town Justin marale in a green room
instantly I'm like oh this night is just
about having fun and enjoying ourselves
so I just love that and I love we always
tell you this I love what you're doing
on stage how you approach it is so great
I just am like could not be a bigger fan
of your standup oh wow thank you not so
much a fan of you as a
person let's get into the stories love
you dude uh so happy Holidays happy
holidays I'm just preparing you for a
Thanksgiving with your relatives right
love what you do don't like is wor that
that just goes ACR like every
Thanksgiving day just check all the
boxes while you're you're a doctor
you're an [__] all right I'm going to
get into this cuz the world's getting
dummer we got to get into it somehow
some way our fan cent of stories this
one was sent in by Matthew Freedman at
average AVG Matt if you want to follow
this guy he's fantastic here is the
headline okay Florida man we're in
Florida sure arrested after throwing a
piece of deli meat at police officer
video shows we got video evidence this
is the off that's a bunch of baloney
uhhuh get out come on why would I Port
Orange Florida have we done stories from
here never heard of Port Orange Florida
have you performed in Florida recently
or no no no no Port Orange Florida the
quickness with which he dispensed I mean
I'll get there one day they just need to
figure it out sure just Port Orange
Florida is like we're just like a barrel
of hookers will roll up rolled up on the
the port where they come from that's
where all the mail order brides come in
from Florida got a whole shipment of
mail order rdes in they come through
Port Orange feels like the golf side
right Port Orange probably it sells like
scurvy and citrus you know right got a
case of Port Orange yeah Port Orange
Police Department posted a video shitty
wine is it it's like port wine but it
has a real strong orange flavor to it
orange wine you know how you it's like a
lost Harry Potter butterbeer flavor
right exactly you're like what's it made
from we let the oranges ferment for
seven years they tell us and they tell
all rind every bottle tells us when we
should serve it yeah we will sell no
rind before it's time okay the the Port
Orange Police Department posted a video
of the incident to Facebook of course
cuz the police department is like your
aunt only operating on Facebook which
shows William Bucy bu USI okay busy booy
buy bie
uh do you guys know what a [__] is no
come on what is
aussy tell them you know what a butle
[__] yeah thank you
yeah come on I don't know the season
guys God happy holidays
holidays happy holidays buy years it's
the most wonderful busy of the year so
will py roasting on an open
fire busy
Bells busy Bells Frost nipping at your
taint right uh become aggravated with an
officer before chucking the mystery
lunch meat you can figure out what it is
can you I don't know like if it's a
Lunchable there's no way to actually
striking the officer where so where he
strikes the officer will determine
whether you who you think overreacted
here in the face oh well okay I'll stick
with my guess but I feel differently
know in the mouth what do you think well
you said face and mouth and striking
yeah I'll go with neck neck
okay less it's like foot a piece of meat
in the chest okay that was close if
you're wearing a bulletproof vest and th
someone throws a piece of head cheese at
your chest it ricocheted off the Kevlar
and it knocked me to my
backside so in the video a clerk inside
of a smoke shop told the officer she
called about a disturbance after a man
later identified as Bucy visited the
store several times and bothered her and
the customers she also said the officer
uh told the officer the man made her
feel uncomfortable and said a lot of
vulgar things to her grabbed merchandise
and tried to go behind the counter this
is a bad person yeah when the officer
approached buy outside or busy busy he
said uh he was arrested about 8 months
ago and spent 18 months in prison that's
a good way to open a conversation with
the that's what he said to the cop
that's like him saying that's like when
you put the parking ticket on your car
they you already have so they don't give
you another one before you say anything
here's what I did
wrongest 18 months in prison so whatever
I did in there I've already served the
time that's his I did my time that's
your
opening what I did my time so busy told
the officer that he was suing the valua
county sheriff so like that's also what
to know about someone when in the first
breath of talking to someone they' tell
you about the lawsuit they're involved
with the cops with the cops right he's
suing the police department for wrong
for wrong but he threw the deli me
that's comes later this is not this is
opening remarks opening remarks is I was
already in jail whatever you going to
tell me in there I was already in jail
also I'm already in with you guys I've
already sued your ass yeah do you want
me to sue you again and I'll do it again
I'm going to add it to the list yeah
suing the Valia County sheriff and asked
if he sued the port and asked if he sued
the Port Orange Police department for
blank how much money whether that would
be taxfree or not he said if I sue you
and win and get the money would that be
money tax so again the officer's like
dude I don't know because you're
bothering people the truth is what do I
need to pay a lawyer if we get into a
suit if I sue you because I'm already in
with the volucia if I sue you like I'm
suing them and I and I win because I'm
going to win is that money taxfree
that's such a weird Flex how much money
did he say he was going to sue them for
million dollars million what do you
think $50,000 I was going to say 50 as
well okay you got to pick a different
one cuz he picked 50 oh yeah uh
51,000 get your answers in toes he said
if I sue the uh Port Orange Police
Department for
$250,000 would that be taxfree listen to
this guy Bucy the officer said he had no
idea to which busy said that would have
to speak he would have to speak to his
accountant about that oh do you think
this guy has no he does not have an
accountant okay when the officer told
busy that the clerk inside the smoke
shop called to say that he was bothering
customers he said the aren't you so
curious as to how we're going to get
from smoke shop to loose meat right he
said the clerk told him to be quiet and
leave which he claims to have done I did
it I did it sure it's her word against
mine yeah the officer told Bucy if he
goes back in the store he'd be
trespassing adding he is no longer
allowed to go inside
busy didn't like that he then told the
officer the clerk would have to tell me
where to go okay so he then told the
officer that the clerk would have to put
his $2,000 worth of merchandise outside
the store which he claimed she was
holding can we just set this building on
fire god this is the most tedious
discussion anyone has ever been in I'm
like please throw balone at my face to
get me
off said quote go ask her go ask her
right now ask her you [__] oh
and as busy got angry he threatened the
officer to come closer so he could brawl
there's nothing worse than an angry
busy he said come closer so we can brawl
so he could brawl he's like brawl
doesn't get used enough are you in a
saloon what is this it's like lizo
talking to her backup dancers is getting
very violent very fast so like lizo
slammed down her flute and then said
whatever
she her back get closer this guy slam
down his sandwich come closer to me
slammed his sandwich down on a bench put
up his Dukes that's what it says right
here taunting the officer to throw down
and attempted to perform a karate kick
attempted which means he didn't do it
didn't do it he tried he tried also I'm
still back on how good a sandwich sounds
right now okay just a good deli meat
sand again because this guy can't just
attempt a karate kick he has to tell you
where he is in the karate pecking order
I got a black belt in karate and a black
belt in Judo busy said you're going to
be in a world of hurt whenever somebody
says that that I have a black belt in
karate and Judo like real fast they
don't mean it so you know who doesn't
say they have a black belt in karate and
Judo people have black belts in karate
and they just kick your ass and like you
didn't see it coming seeing and then
someone else goes you didn't know he has
a black belt she's a black Bel quote
yeah when you're good at something you
tell everybody when you're great at
something they tell you they tell you
mhm busy then told the officer he was
going to take his gun and walkie-talkie
before driving off in his patrol car I
just like the boldness I'm going to take
your gun I'm going to take your
walkie-talkie why cuz I'm a black belt
in Judo and that I'm going to drive off
in your car this
dog he attempted a kick after having a
few more words with the officers who
reminded him that he was trespassing
Bussy then reached down in his sandwich
and threw a piece of deli meat at the
officer striking him in the chest
striking is not the right word no I
would have said I would have used tased
like way before we got to this
incapacitating yeah just this is the if
I were writing this article he then
picked up a piece of deli meat and lobed
it towards the offic at the police
officer and it hilariously stuck to his
chest is what I would say
like go ahead arrest me busy said so the
officer did busy was placed in handcuffs
I'm assuming with no fight whatsoever
walked over the w walked over the police
vehicle on the way he told the officer
he was going to sue the police officer
for how much he gave two amounts here
how much he's going to sue this guy sue
the cop for arresting him adding that he
would be out in how much time he said
I'm going to sue you for how much what
which one are we guessing how much is he
going to sue him for like he mad at now
you're arresting me I'm going to sue you
for a blank amount of money okay
$100,000 what do you think Dan I'll
stick with a mill what do you think I'm
going to say a million on this one so
get your answers in he said I'm going to
see you for a million or 10 million okay
or 10 million so anyone adding I'll be
out in how much time 2 hours a week two
weeks 30 minutes damn this guy is
unbelievable he's dominoes he knows when
I asked why he threw some in the police
officer busy said because he was pissed
off at him and he was acting like a jerk
busy also told the officer he was lucky
he didn't have his pocket knife on him
this guy yeah because he would have
stabbed the officer to death yeah no
[__] what what other reason do we think
you stop making threats at police
officers you need busy
control very true this is why I want you
along on every ride along just to be
like the person to make the person feel
bad after this he ultimately was
arrested for a battery of a law
enforcement officer a battery by
throwing the meat that's a salt I guess
I mean it's a salty piece of
meat the Port Orange Police Department
shared the video on Facebook giving
people a crash course and in clude
Behavior sure to backfire in this city
like disrupting a business and
threatening workers threatening officers
imagining that you have black belts in
karate and Judo this you don't have to
say iMagic maybe he does have going and
hitting officers in the chest with lunch
meat he is arrested this is he may be
one of my favorite characters that we've
met at this you've heard of Lunchables
this guy is punchable punch all right
that's Story number one we come back
we'll tell you what we have going on
tell you how you can follow Justin
marale see him live listen to his
amazing podcast which we will all do at
some point uh this is D people town with
Justin marale we'll be right
[Music]
back hey guys welcome back to the show
in the break we were talking about this
guy busy going to prison and uh you said
Beware that he becomes a guy whose
Legend grows in prison yes beware the
meat tosser meat thrower me thrower I
think meat tosser cuz he's hang out with
the salad tosser it is prison gang yes
yes beat you with his meat double on
tandas thank you before we get into what
Justin marale has going on we should
tell you what we have going on gang
we're in Cleveland on December 1st and
2nd at hilarities I love that club so
much I love that Nick who runs that club
is great and the people come out it's
just a great comedy City Portland we're
only there for one night January 4th
yeah we're going to be at Helium on
January 4th and on the 5th we're in
Seattle at the crocodile I love that
club too uh beginning of February we're
at Comedy Works South I love that club
and then uh we go back to the first club
we ever performed and got paid at Mark
Ridley's Comedy Castle a at the
beginning of March then beginning of
April we're Minneapolis at Acme and then
end of April at moon tower more dates to
come it's suers cl.com thank you for
following us and joining our patreon
where we do episodes of cheap seats and
cheaper seats this patreon where we give
you extra stories we love you guys thank
you so much uh Justin marale you have a
fantastic podcast just saying just
saying with Justin marale saying yep
Comedy Store records great guests that
you have on this and again if you love
on this podcast which I'm sure you do go
uh subscribe to his podcast and it's a
new one for you if you don't know about
it's a delight it's a delight cuz you're
a delight it's a fun one yeah that one
and then I will be in Colorado Springs
at the three East Comedy Club December
1st and 2 there you go Colorado Colorado
Springs uh I'm a regular on uh Jeff
Lewis live on SiriusXM so you can listen
to that Monday lucky to have you Jeff
Lewis is lucky to have you and I'm sure
he appreciates you yeah he does he doesz
all right let me get this story this was
sent by
MC a great person who sent stuff in all
the time I love this a Delaware man
admitted that he drunkenly snapped the
thumb off of a ancient Chinese statue
and swiped it and we'll guess how much
the statue was I thought calgan was the
ancient Chinese was it a a statue get
into ancient statue BR you know cuz
people feel like if you see something
out in the world you can just take it
and take destroy ity oh that's for me
it's this world belongs to me so I can
just I can treat it how I treat my stuff
um a Delaware man pleaded guilty in
Pennsylvania Court on Monday to a
federal MISD your problem first is a
Delaware man in Pennsylvania those two
things don't mix you're not from around
here are you you from Delaware all right
misdemeanor charge related to drunkenly
breaking off and stealing the thumb of
an ancient Chinese statue
worth how much we're going already
ancient Chinese
statue what dynasty yeah we don't
know the fing Dynasty Dynasty break me
off a thumb of that ancient Chinese
statue how much is a I mean the only
ancient I just think of like the ones
outside of a PF
Changs so so those are like 15 years old
that's not that ancient I mean ancient
Chinese statue uh
what's it worth
itself five million is that way too much
that's way too much no I I'm going to
say like
$750,000 I it's a lot of money I'll say
I would suck at Antique Road Show right
600,000 600,000 all right get your an in
my gave this to me this ancient Chinese
statu is with $4.5
million be great at antiqu Road I would
be great at anti Road show comedy see
you later what if this guy ripped the
thumb off and tried to take the thumb to
the Antiques Road show we know quite a
bit of money prosecutors first charged
Michael Rohana the Rihanna of ancient
Chinese Rohana in 2018 with the theft
and concealment of an object of cultural
heritage from a museum as well as
interstate transportation of stolen
property which could have landed him
into prison for how many years yeah you
can't take a piece of a thumb across
state lines up to how many years could
he be in prisoned 25 years you say s
what do you
say 12 how about 30 years w w wow
according to the Washington Post I
actually think that that seems like
appropriate yeah I do too it's not your
thumb bro not your thumb and it means so
much to so many other people thumb who's
got three thumbs and is a total [__]
this guy this guy Rohana Rohan but
Monday's guilty plead to one misdemeanor
count of trafficking in archaeological
resources means he now only faces how
many years so he he pleaded guilty so
now oh yeah he kep knocked it six uh I'm
going to go with his 12 damn it I was
going to do 12 again I'll say uh 15 all
right one year in prison 30 down to one
wow they just went okay this guy's going
to I mean he definitely should get a
thumb up the ass in prison and he
probably's going to get out in 3 months
meanwhile Deli thrower is like I could
have been out in 30
minutes yes in 2017 Rohanna was
attending an ugly sweater Christmas
party at the Franklin museum in
Philadelphia say no more now we know
everything right yeah there was rum
punch mistakes photo booth also don't
have your Christmas party at a museum
yeah yeah no yeah hey want to go to
museum to to look at all the wonderful
art nope do you want to get trashed
around expensive things yeah let's do
horrible idea is it an open bar
yeah in a museum what could go wrong so
he tapestry no that's I'm going to lay
down in it do not lay down the m d when
you lean on it it falls apart
sucks what's the thread count I count
four this place sucks right Rohanna
snuck away from the party on December
21st and into the Terracotta Warriors
ex which was closed to partygoers but
clearly no one's blocking his way what
you should keep these drunk people out
of here well and in what what museum
doesn't have lasers okay number one and
number two like the worst thing a museum
could ever hear is somebody stumbling
into a room saying hey what's in here
yeah in a Christmas
sweater bad one which was closed party
goers and featured several terracotta
sculptures of Warriors from the tomb of
China's first emperor according to the
2018 affidavit F by the FBI art crime
team the sculptures which are dated from
what year
years I I mean the
1600s oh oh first emperor I don't know
hold on I'm watching Outlander are you
come on get in there get go to your
Outlander History Justin and start going
through it westw World season let's get
into it yes I'm with you with that West
World
15 the year 15
1560s I think the year 6
ad how about 210 to 209
B over
2,00 200 years old and some drunk guy in
a bad Christmas sweater just scw has
access to this with his drunk hands no
that's like the first Chinese emperor
that's right they were on loan they were
on loan from China and are a Priceless
part of the country's cultural heritage
like this could start a war like China
would start a war over this Dan you know
they would Rohana used his phone's
flashlight to to make his way around the
dimly lit room this no flash photography
he definitely didn't turn it off after
that no he left on took it off and took
a selfie with a sculpture in the exhibit
space that's enough that was NE forti
she she wanted the selfie already the
guy is the worst person in the world
then he goes according to affidavit the
affidavit said he then broke something
off one of the statues and put it in his
front pocket citing surveillance footage
Rohanna took the thumb from a statue
referred to as the C man which was I
hope he's cursed now oh absolutely I was
going to say that the curse of the
broken thumb yeah the curse of the
broken thumb on Are You Afraid of the
Dark it's I was going to say it's like
the sister it's like The Sisterhood of
the Traveling thumb yeah uh it was
insured for $4.5 million and brought
back to his family's home in Bear
Delaware when FBI agent visiting the
property in February 2018 uh visited the
property in 2018 Rohan immediately
confessed to swiping oh the thumb FBI
agent and you better say it right there
and retrieved it from a desk drawer in
his bedroom oh I love that it's sitting
in there with your old check of paper
thank God he kept it though yeah oh this
thumb this thumb yeah yeah I got it
right over here it's like if you did it
when you were so blackout drunk you'd be
like wait what's this how do I get this
yeah then you give it right back snapped
off you would think he'd be
like you know he's like I'll take this
and he just put it in there and it's
like holding all of his rubber bands are
around it all right in in April 2019
trial Rohana told jur it was a stupid
mistake attorney Katherine C Hendry told
jurors that Rohan wasn't an art Thief
merely a drunk kid in a bright green
ugly Christmas sweater that should go on
his Tombstone sure here lies a drunk kid
in a not an art Thief he's a drunk guy
and a dumb Christmas was he a kid they
say he was a kid a jury was unable to
reach a decision resulting in the
Declaration of a mistrial what a retrial
was scheduled for February 2020 but it
was repeatedly delayed due to the
covid-19 pandemic wait a minute this is
how much people don't care about art in
this part of the country and a
deterioration in us China relations
rohan's sentencing is scheduled for
August 17th you know that there's
probably some sentiment in the jury pool
like good give it to China yeah this
they gave us they gave us Co we'll take
your thumb a CO for a thumb and you gave
us Tik Tok and you're watching us and
you're monitoring our every move we got
and I a CO for a thumb for a thumb isn't
that crazy stumbling around with his
iPhone camera on the light on and the
Selfies and but I mean now it's like I
feel like there's these like oil
activists now throwing beans on
portraits and ketchup and all that and
they're like we here to stop this and
it's like that's just broad daylight on
a Tuesday right and you're not doing
anything to you're bringing attention to
your cause but it's not it's the worst
it's the worst attention ever it's like
no one's going to be like oh man you
guys just ruin the Mona Lisa we should
really stop killing the whales you
they're making really good points
they're making really good points about
the environment it's like don't make me
get mad at you when I agree with your
environmental stance like don't now make
me against you cuz now he like come on
now you're turning us we take a break my
mouth yeah sorry you missed your mouth
drinking we're going to take a break
Dan's going to send us home with uh what
give me a little taste of what we're
going to hear oh we're going to go back
in
time H Le capacitor fluxing and we'll
find out what Dan's got going on it's D
people Town Justin marale is our guest
we'll be right
back so we're in the holiday season and
so hoopdee doop hoopdee doop and a
Scoopy scoop and your life is a hoopdee
hoop Scoopy scoop oh gosh mess of all
these things like I just know your days
are packed in a different way and we're
so busy you get home at 6:00 you've
thought nothing about what you're going
to do for dinner you don't know how
you're going to prepare food that's
interesting and that isn't the same old
food rut that you've been in before and
you don't even have the time to prepare
like a longterm meal situation you want
something quick and good cleaning up
after the meal is like death for me too
so I I love what factor has done first
of all the variety of choices are
amazing and the food ISO fito oh so good
fresh never Frozen pesto chicken is
awesome the pesto salmon salmon salmon
is so good so my daughter loves salmon
and I I she had the pesto salmon she's
like never had pesto on salmon before
she loves it she wants it everywhere I'm
like it's at factor it's breakfast items
lunch on the go little snacks they're
just so good I Know Dan you're a huge
proponent and have been for a while but
the great thing is guys you can head to
factor meals.com right now it's factor
meals.com
dp50 and use code dp50 to get 50% off
that's code dp50 factor meals.com
dp50 to get
50%
off hey unwrap the first of many
presents this season with holidays on
the house from DraftKings casino with
hundreds of games prizes and promos
DraftKings Casino has everything on your
list right now new players who play $5
get
$100 instantly in Casino credits what
are you waiting for cozy up with all the
classics like slots Blackjack and
roulette or play exclusive games you'll
only find at DraftKings casino to feel
the holiday cheer I love a good I love a
good Casino experience I'll do the slots
I'll do blackjack
do you have your numbers for roulette do
you guys have like yes I do have three
no one should take our advice no one
take our advice but I'm saying my
numbers are 21 and I love seven 21's
good I go like five eight I like 11 do a
13 20 I'll do a 13 saw 13 hit four times
in a row uh there's hundreds of
variations at casino games you'll find
that fits your taste at DraftKings
casino app low minimum so you can play
as low or high stakes as you feel on a
given day no uh if you're not ready
ready to play for real money this is the
this is so much F fun you do it for fun
yeah you can just test uh test out games
for free see how you do if you start
kicking butt then boom you're in the
game see what you like guys download the
DraftKings casino app now sign up with
the promo code DPT play $5 to get $100
in Casino credits that's promo code DPT
onlyd draftkings.com the crown is yours
yeah gambling problem call 1-800 Gambler
or visit www. 1800 gambler. net J tell
them in the states in Connecticut help
is available for problem gambling call
888 78977 77 or visit ccpg toorgle play
responsibly 21 plus physically present
in Connecticut Michigan New Jersey
Pennsylvania West Virginia only void in
Ontario elig eligibility and deposit
restrictions apply one per opted in new
customer $5 wager required Max $100 in
Casino credit awarded which requires one
times playr within 7 Days terms at
casino. draftkings.com
holidays on the house restrictions
[Music]
apply hey gang welcome back to the show
before we Dan takes us home on this
final fun quick little third segment
story Dan tell us where people can see
you you're touring December 14th I'm
headlining at Cap City in Austin
Texas and you can check out other dates
at daniel.com the Rose Gold Tour will
continue until the special drops and
that will be sometime in the spring so
look for dates in the Pacific Northwest
the west coast and all around and then
also my movie is out wine club movie um
you're the Le finder you can correct me
if I'm wrong but you the lead in that
movie some people say my movie and
they've got a scene in it Dan Dan isn't
my movie it's his movie I Am the lead uh
wine club movie check it out uh wherever
I don't know if pred yet but um Daniel
van.com yeah all that information and
just follow Dan on Instagram and T and
all that other stuff because he'll let
you know where stuff is let's do sent in
by Jeremy Kendrick jsk uncore
isore here great jsk I don't think this
person is sent in so this is really cool
to have a newer person man trying trying
to travel through time smash his car
through Florida businesses of course
yeah wait I have not seen you said get
the flux capacitor of fluxing that's
when you're going 80 and you're like I
should be my tire tire's not on fire
wait how come I not transfer to another
dimension why isn't my mom trying to
have sex with me so you know he
definitely got into the store got out of
the car and said is this 1986 where am I
what year is this what year is this
who's the president just no you know
what's crazy is like he does need a time
machine to go back in time and undo all
the bad decisions don't let him think
that he would know that he could go
through time he definitely just watched
it back to the future when do you
realize that you know when you think you
could go back in time you know you're
like it's it's a Wednesday you know what
I'm going to do I go back in time does
he have a time machine yeah what does he
we're going to dig into it although I do
really want to see the musical I hear
it's very very fun I heard it's good
back to the future of the musical yeah
oo a confused man who thought he was
time traveling smashed his car through
two businesses say police a Dodge
Challenger already already like I can
get up to
88 in this parking lot I can get up to
88 Dodge challender you're just
never the nicest person on the road was
he smuggling plutonium we don't know
Dodge Challenger is definitely someone
who's like I'm I'm right and you're
wrong a lot I've never seen a Dodge
Challenger slow down to let you merge in
front of them not once they've never
they're never the one doing the dump I
mean they're fun to drive let's be
honest but still the Dodge Challenger
plowed through two businesses in
Pensacola Florida uh strip mall on
Sunday morning according to Pensacola
News Journal the driver sped through the
intersection of North Davis Highway in
West ffield Drive at
approximately what time want to take a
guess o 10:00 a.m. I'm going to say it
was busy I'm going to say like 1 mhm 1
p.m. what do you think
Jason 4 one of you is in the right hour
10:50 a.m. open he's like look I got to
get back in time I can't wait all day to
get back in time cleared to the front
door of Advanced Tax Services the car
then kept going which is sort of a
commentary on the construction
businesses wanted to beat the time
change he's counting he's taking it as a
deductible sming through the wall and
into the business next door oh which was
a massage parlor and all these children
were I was kind of hoping it was like an
old time photography studio he would
have thought he went back in time one of
those Theme Park photos wouldn't that
just be the best if he goes and there's
a family just standing there like
hookers from like in a saloon era like
dust era like poverty he's like I did it
let's dress up like the olden days he's
like I have a war I'm in a wh house yeah
like an escape room like in a themed
escape room yeah oh that would be great
like it's like he breaks into like a
like an insane asylum from like 1910 oh
my God guys I'm going to be honest I'll
show you the picture he [__] this car
up oh my God lord yeah yeah he went
plowing through he did not stop it
looked like a bomb went off Advan Tax
Services general manager Emanuel Mor we
can claim as a deduction like
they not our fault not an act of
God from and we had a great year so this
actually balanced everything out nicely
police said the unidentified driver told
them he was quote trying to travel
through time which technically you you
are doing so and he didn't finish the
sentence travel through time so that to
get her back so she wouldn't break up
but do we also get the blood do we get
to guess the blood alcohol level
when it's in here we always we always do
instead he traveled through two present
time businesses causing huge amounts of
damage that was a that was a that was a
d I'm sorry it just got a lot darker in
here shade got thrown by this article
wait dan can we just for one second just
that is the type of thing of go back in
time to the point in time that she broke
up with me and whatnot I feel like and I
not want to generalize but I feel like
that is very heterosexual like they hang
on to it so much that like too much that
I'm going to go back I'm going to
actually bend the concept of time I feel
like no gay man would be like just just
like whatever who cares let me check
grinder real quick you know no I want to
fast forward and get rid of this person
all right well that was funny yeah well
that was great well it
lasted uh according to the huffing post
the man was from Nashville so yeah and
had 1947 and seat belt on during the
crash and was not he stated that he was
driving at high speeds on the interstate
an attempt to enter a time portal he saw
Back to the Future period 88 milph there
you go and that he did not leave the
time portal until the crash occurred so
he's saying he had come back he was
coming back out of another time that
sent him through a uh shopping center
got it the driver has reportedly been
issued a citation for reckless driving
and it's also in the hospital being
evaluated moris said he was mad about
the incident but had it it could have
been worse eventually I was happy that
no one was hurt you know that was my
biggest concern because if anyone was
hurt anybody could have died or whatever
that's the dumbest was this just the guy
from Ferris Bueller in succession yeah
did you hear about that he just like
crashed into a pizza
place yeah yeah what's his name
what's Alan rck really yeah yeah uh
luckily no one was inside the two
businesses when the when the time
traveler struck stop calling him a time
traveler just let him have it it's his
moment you know oh my gosh he identifies
as a time I found out we're about to
find out what the place next door the
second business was canot wait should we
all guess yeah sure if you want okay uh
you're not going to get it it's too
great it's it's like a color me mind
when and all these kids Pottery just got
ruined what is the question again what
is the buiness second business that he
went through the tax office and oh yeah
okay so there's no way you'll guess
there's no way I'll get it it's too
great but you guess for fun so can
someone help me also with this one
Massage
Envy but I understand it but I don't
understand the title well it's is it
like a penis envy thing massage EnV
jealous you're not there you're jealous
you're very envious of this massage but
you're there yes but you're there if
you're at the place I have Massage Envy
it doesn't even sound like penis it's
true like it should like if I had a
store that sold peanuts and they called
it peanuts Envy I'd be like n that's
funny you want Massage Envy do you want
to guess this it's better than it's
better than you're going to what if it's
a clock shop that's called times up you
know that's pretty
great that would be fun or they sell
tiny clock towers tiny clocks from
around the world Ellison Bennett the
co-owner of Pensacola caskets no not
Pensacola
caskets where are you located we're over
right next to the T trying to buy our
product Oh God you need a casket we all
do we'll airbrush a Seascape on it okay
located next door to Advanced Tax
Services says he has not been able to
enter his business but he too is Happy
it wasn't worse if this had happened on
a weekday and someone had actually been
in one of those cubicles it would have
been very tragic yes of course that's
exactly what would have happened I mean
the truth is that like I think the
caskets being like the caskets place it
they'd want more people it to be busy
cuz then they'd have more business right
is that wrong but also now I'm seeing a
sight gag of this man crashing through
the office flying through the windshield
into a casket and then it closing which
is which would be that's a rim shot
that's it that's like that's the end of
a Benny Hill thing bunny
yeah yes he flies to the windshield
through the windshield open castet shs
um Jason had to step out but we'll get
out of here on this how old is the man
from Nashville who was time traveling in
a Dodge I think it was Challenger
Challenger yeah this is challeng he he
was coming out of a portal when when he
drove into tax ta and should just
combine their business and you know he
definitely said I can't control where
the portal spits me out you know no why
do these two businesses not combine what
they are and call it the only things
guaranteed death and taxes I would just
put that over the two things yes we
guarantee everything death and tax taxes
that's a great great call what is your
guess how old do you think how old is
Nashville man is okay all right oh Jason
has returned how old do you think the
Nashville man is do you want to go first
you're a guest where would you like to
go you like I'm going to say 52 okay I'm
going to say 67 all right Jason 28
28 we'll get out of here with the time
traveling Dodge Challenger death and
taxes business destroy war is is 40
years old wow J app this this is 40 was
40 who knows what time
is D town is a flat circle that is there
you go but there's nothing that says
what what year he thought he came from
no but I would as the cop you'd want to
get as much I would want to know so much
year are you from Sir yeah where were
you going tell me more about where from
2939 two months ago hey hey man who
crashed through a tax uh place
and tell me what the future's all about
that'd be the greatest all right we'll
tell you what the future is more D more
dumb people tell we'll do that uh not
now but uh with future episodes Justin
marale again just saying follow his
podcast listen to it we'll all be on and
it's going to be a blast and thanks for
joining us dude anytime boys this is
always fun and oh [__] we got to get
back to
work
boom sck around
make sound there's more
[Music]
town